turning now to the pandemic the latest
coveted surge is hitting florida harder
than most states there are now more
cases there than ever before and with
the delta variant children are more
vulnerable to serious illness all this
has led to a legal battle in florida
over what schools can do to keep kids
safe
a judge is expected to rule today on the
governor's ban on mask mandates manuel
bojorquez is following all of it from
miami
we were scared that the return of school
was going to become a super spreader
before the school year began this week
francella guidochacon protested and
petitioned to make masks mandatory in
her ten-year-old daughter's district
that mask is not
a political statement it's not a fashion
choice it's a safety
device
the efforts were successful now
miami-dade school kids like more than
half of the state's 2.8 million students
must wear masks with limited exceptions
but that could change based on a judge's
ruling in a trial that is pitting
parents like ido chacon against governor
ron desantis and florida education
officials parents are in the better
position to make the decision about
whether their kids should be wearing the
mass in school particularly young kids
desantis has threatened to withhold some
state funding from districts with
mandates arguing they are violating the
so-called parents bill of rights a law
passed this year that gives parents more
discretion over a child's education some
parents would save your decision
shouldn't be imposed upon their child
what do you say that would be
correct if there was not a pandemic
the fact that we're in an emergency
health crisis
kind of takes away their choice because
now it's a health crisis former cdc
director dr thomas frieden says masks
are crucial for children who aren't yet
eligible for a vaccine the mask that you
wear protects people around you the mask
that other people wear protects you and
that's why universal masking indoors is
so powerful
today's expected court ruling could
determine how districts across the state
including the largest miami-dade county
deal with the pandemic and the debate
comes as the number of cases and
hospitalizations of children skyrocket
across the country
cases have more than quadrupled since
the end of july gail
thank you very much manny the kids
really do seem to be rolling with the
mask my nephews are you know 12 and 15
16 and no problems it's the parents who
are not rolling exactly exactly exactly